we've had a very stimulating afternoon
session opening the symposium and I'm
pleased to welcome students faculty and
guests back into the room or rooms I
should say and to the keynote lecture in
the symposium is drawing dead convened
by George Knight and Viktor Agron
critics in our school whom I wish to
thank and I think we all will join me I
hope you all join me in thanking him
them for the tremendous work of
scholarship that is represented by this
symposium
I also wish to thank Massimo scolari who
opened the proceedings last night with
his lecture representations coinciding
with the inauguration of his exhibition
in our gallery
Massimo scolari the representation of
architecture which professor scolari
curated with the assistance of Brian
Butterfield and designed with the
assistance of Brian Butterfield director
of exhibitions and Laura Selva screen II
and which was is interpreted in an
excellent catalogue xsa by Dan Shara
lecturer in history and theory in our
school tonight before this evenings
keynote I would also like to express my
appreciation to the very many who helped
make the organization of this weekend's
event possible and going as smoothly as
it is at least until now especially our
schools associate dean john jacobson and
our schools events coordinators Richard
to flummery
and Barbie when annoyed and on behalf of
the students and faculty I want to
welcome the many symposium participants
who honor us with their presence and
their scholarship is drawing dead is the
second J Irwin Miller symposium the J
Irwin Miller fund the first fund in our
school to dedicate resources expressly
in support of symposia was established
in 2010 through the extraordinary
generosity of mr. Miller's children
Catherine Margaret Elizabeth and will I
am deeply grateful to the Miller family
for choosing to the honour to honor the
memory of their father through this
partnership with the School of
Architecture J Irwin Miller was a 1931
Phi Beta Kappa graduate of Yale College
as an undergraduate his major subject
was Greek and Latin how many are Greek
and Latin students do we have now after
Yale he continued his education at
Oxford University where he studied
philosophy politics and economics at
Balliol College in three in 1934 miss
Miller began his professional career
with the family business Cummins engine
company ultimately serving as president
from 1947 to 51 and chairman thereafter
until 1977 during World War two mr.
Miller saw active duty as a lieutenant
in the u.s. Navy in the South Pacific
I have the privilege of getting to know
her when Miller and his wife Xenia near
the ends of their lives they were among
the most remarkable people I've ever
encountered mr. Miller was one in a
million a successful businessman a
pillar of his church a loyal alumnus of
Yale who served as a corporation fellow
from 1959 to 1977 and a fierce advocate
of freedom of choice for an opportunity
for all Aaron Miller was an outstanding
citizen second to none the embodiment of
ethical behavior a model for each of us
tonight sir Peter crook Sabina cook will
deliver the keynote lecture which will
be followed with a response from
Stanislaus Vaughn most Vincent Scully
visiting professor in architectural
history in our school Peter Cook founder
of ARCA gram and former director of the
Institute of Contemporary Arts in London
and the Bartlett School of Architecture
at University College London has been a
pivotal figure within the global
architectural world after for over half
a century
Peter Cook's accomplishments as part of
the radical experimental group ARCA
Graham have been the subject of numerous
publications and exhibitions in the
1960s arca Graham transformed the
boundaries of architectural
possibilities for a rebellious
generation Peter Cook has from the very
beginning of his career made waves as a
theorist operating at the margins of the
architecture profession however with the
construction of his Arts Building the
Constance Graz iak in a the friendly
alien in Graz Austria which he designed
a partnership with Colin Fournier he
work can now be encountered by a wider
public a process that set to continue
with the construction of the Vienna
Business and Economic University's new
law facility the history of 20th century
architecture cannot be complete without
the consideration of ARCA gram but
superiors works sue Peters work as
director of the art net and London
curator of the British Pavilion at the
Venice architectural Biennale as well as
numerous exhibitions that he has
organized around the world and his work
as a building architect are also and
indeed are of immense importance
starting out in the 1960s as the UM font
Arriba of the anti-establishment
in 2004 he was awarded the gold medal of
the Royal Institute of British
Architects how times change and in 2007
he was knighted by the Queen for his
services to architecture and teaching so
even if you're a tall font to rebook you
can become a Sir Peter cook's 2008 book
drawing published by Wiley is the
spiritual backbone of this symposium for
architects today it is for the
definitive contemporary discussion of
the topic beautifully written from the
head and the heart
drawing copies of drawing will be
available for sale in her school's
gallery following this evenings program
and Sir Peter will be available to sign
them now it's my great pleasure to
welcome sir Peter Cook to Yale as he
delivers the lecture real is only
halfway there Peter Cook
I guess shock was the situation that
faced me one day in the architectural
dissociation where I taught alongside
this guy who some of you probably know
Dalia Vasily a Czech intellectual who
hangs out in London and sometimes I
believe at Penn he we were just spending
a typical afternoon we'd been on a jury
and Dalit war said buildings don't
matter
drawings matter much much more than
buildings and that was my shock I I I
was horrified now you have to put it
into a personal perspective because that
was at the moment when I hadn't hardly
built anything I was I was also known as
a drawing person and yet this comment
abdalian was totally shocked me and
still shocks me and yet and yet because
in choosing the title real is only
halfway there I'm really alluding to
something quite difficult what I'm
trying to talk about is for me quite
difficult because it's a sort of
intangible I hope that I won't entirely
talk about drawing as drawing I'm a
fraud anyhow I was a very poor drawer as
I left grammar school and went to my
first architecture school in provincial
Bournemouth Iram in that rather poor
place there were people who could draw
better than me
and of course subsequently yeah and
subsequently in sort of looking after
the Bartlett there have been always many
many people down the corridor who can
draw better than me some people very
close to me
Ron Herron the late Ron Herron David
Green Christine Holy See Jane Lim
to Maine but for people who can outdraw
me at the drop of a hat and of course
the wonderful Mike Webb oh I shall talk
about a bit later but I struggled with
it because it seemed to me immensely
important to be able to communicate
ideas to try and discover ideas and what
other way then drawing yes I could I
could make cathedrals out of balsa wood
but that wasn't enough and I I think
there's something of the sort of Puritan
ethic there I say it in in suggesting
there for that because drawing has been
a struggle that I'm a little bit
dismissive of all these methods that are
now available to anybody that don't
involve struggle but that would need to
be a psychologist to get under that one
Mamie
one of the things that intrigues me is
the question of drawing in relation to
itself in relation to what it means and
there are I don't like alliterations but
there are three C words that seem to
come up one is the word culture which I
think in in the lectures that I listen
to today so far has been sitting there
all the time it's and I like to think of
one's position as as sometimes a maker
of drawing is being pulled by the
culture around you or the culture that
you've set up around you even sometimes
and the drawing can somehow push that
culture it could it's actually involved
in in in a dynamic condition and that's
what I really still very much feel
drawing is a dynamic issue then there's
a more tricky issue of craft isn't it
interesting that's in the heyday of all
those small architecture galleries that
used to exist in Europe and elsewhere
and even now that the beauty of the
drawn object the the deafness of the
pencil
Toleration needy even how its framed how
its hung high slit sometimes is is is a
Dodger territory because in a sense I
think I use the word here elite but
perhaps what I'm really talking about is
is the academic end of our of the
architecture world I think many people
in the academic end of the architecture
will dismiss anything that's of the hand
of the craft it was interesting
listening to hear hat yeah honey this
afternoon make so much point about this
question of the hand there's an integral
part of the process but the dismissal of
craft that a craftsman that there's so
many universities want their
architecture faculties to become
something that is more of an academic
discipline and that the talented
craftsman is some kind of secondary
being on the other hand the public that
looks at those drawings and even the
parts of the architectural public that
looks at those drawings are fascinated
by the craft how you know I can remember
the man this is the the most elite group
of audience I've ever had but the second
most elite which was many years ago at
Cornell where Peter Smith's and Colin
Rowe and Felix Candela was sitting in
the front row and Ron and I were doing a
joint lecture me said [ __ ] what better
hang in together and and then we braced
ourselves for the question at the end of
the lecture
and the question the only question was
what color pencils do you use so you see
even in their in their in that elite
that situation and that wonderful place
that preoccupies people so III think the
position of the drawing that the drawing
itself is is sitting somewhere between
this this extremely odd position of its
dismissal on the one hand a fascination
with the actual tactility of it is and
then the issue of creativity my feeling
is that many of you sitting here and I
say this is a collective comment to the
east coast of the United States in
architectural circles
that the theory that many of you are
suspicious of creativity don't it's it's
kind of bit too big focuses to do with
the person creativity what's that spooky
spooky stuff and yet my purpose this
evening I will be circling around it
probably not very successfully who knows
around the idea of identifying the
creative moment one of the other things
that deliver another conversation with a
lot perhaps of soft a conversation that
used to prop up was that he would
describe himself as a member of the
valley culture of the austro-hungarian
Empire and it was a useful excuse for
many things and I then alongside him
developed the notion that I was a child
of the North Sea culture this culture of
flat bans and winds and and and you know
strange marsh marshes and I deliberately
therefore want to take two slides from
each of those cultures just to make the
point to come in on this issue of the
culture background about petrol drawings
which is plecnik plecnik after all was
provincial it was from ljubljana it
wasn't really a really really
cosmopolitan and i think that the mere
provincial takes the culture even more
seriously you look at that drawing and
you see how it's in love with a certain
hint of heroism and yet there's also a
hint of the sinister about it and pitch
there was Jana used to pitch this
afternoon we had to do a bit of slide
swapping so it's not to use exactly the
same size but here's pitch slit in
another mood in his his his imitation of
Livie interactionists perhaps his
friends and and he's of course
cerulean Latvia needs one has to
remember that and he's a little bit
close to your neck of the woods for
comfort and and the blood drips just
like those Peter Carr Belka lessons on
on cooking where the the blood passes
through the water
the bone and the bone is worked into the
ground and it's to do with death the as
somebody who's building a building in
Vienna and has built a building in
Grant's I have certain feelings about
the Austrians and they are extremely
sinister in Contra distinction to that
across front I'm taking a very last time
as in this building was to see the the
part of the Sterling Exhibition and I've
chosen a piece of North Sea culture from
sterling and guard who after all also
provincials virtually Scottish one
really Scottish and one from Scottish
blood and it's a very ordinary guy
deliberately chose a rather ordinary
drawing nothing nothing very glamorous
about it you probably wouldn't put it in
a frame unless you had to but the
building is Oh has always been one of my
favorites so in college project which is
that one of those curling British
projects of a certain period and and one
of the most original and if you look
carefully at it it has all the sort of
pragmatism of the North Sea culture it
has nothing little windows it's drawn in
a very ordinary way that makes no bones
about what is the floor
what is the window and the handrail is
very important a handrail this chunky
old piece of mahogany probably is
extremely important and the new key
little window that creeps a bit of
second-rate sunshine into the back of
the building and then the curving of the
concrete's very very important was the
memory of the ship perhaps and in fact
if just start looking at it it's a
rather a rather interesting building it
leans but it's Tom and I think that says
something about the North Sea culture
which has always had to deal with rather
tiresome things such as wind and weather
and and fog and so on or there's the
other aspect of the English culture
famous William Heath Robinson I'm always
been where of the Englishmen they're
being silly that is the moment at which
the
most serious and in fact I think there's
a whole book to be written about the
connection between Heath Robinson and
the British hi-tech movement you stop to
think about it and there's early days in
the sixties when I used to walk past
guys with their feet sticking out of a
underneath the car which would never go
but they would spend the whole weekend
mending it and then go and work for
Richard Rodgers in the daytime and then
celebrate the fact that that like in
Foster's office that they had used the
longest neoprene gasket in the world
which is rather like the Old English
musical trigger jest of the biggest
Astrid Estrin world no for them it was
the longest neoprene gasket and that
that that's sort of silliness which only
elsewhere you find in Japan but I
digress
seriously seriously I could give a whole
afternoon on that question but the
silliness is close in on that inventive
aspect of the North Sea culture because
after all our ancestors had to invent in
order to feeders so the question is what
within the tradition of drawing is
cultures Paul or drawings roll to push
Pichler again and Andy Anna covered this
part of pitch that terribly well is his
his searching for another way away from
into the ground
perhaps it's quite interesting the
pitcher told me once that once he'd been
to South America and seen all the Inca
cities he totally lost interested it
which i think is rather interesting I'm
afraid there'll be a few anecdotes from
time to time thrown in because in the
sense my I'm not a real academic I'm not
a theorist i-i-i-i I sniff around and
I'm interested in people I'm interested
in what people do anything that's funny
he had that reaction then you look next
is another drawing his I think I wonder
what he's up to now if he has that sense
of humor or that sense of disdain or
whatever it might be then then these are
clues but this perhaps comes from
teaching look at pictures drawing where
there is lovemaking captured
fish crumpled paper add one of fishless
tricks that a certain time was to take
shoulder hammer pup here and scrunch it
and twist it and then pass the the ink
across it so that it was already it was
already damaged very very tear aaliyan
thing to do I think
then laterally pivoted they did the
unthinkable
he solely not drawings to build the
building that the drawings were off I
think that's a one night I always
mention that to students I say well
there's this guy in Austria about my age
who so drawings to build the buildings
at the drawing from what a wonderful
loop and across I think it's intriguing
that Pisa has always had this close in
relationship with architects he's not an
architect is he not no not technically
but many many of my friends Peter Wilson
might wear lebbeus father we all talk
about Pichler we've all talked about
picture at great length we've always
been bewitched by pitler even if we were
not of the valley culture and so he
builds the building somebody who is
close in to picture is going to domenica
the many g's is for now incapable of
communication hardly but but but most of
his lifetime has been a close friend of
Peter trying to be as dramatic as
picture actually having been born under
the shadow of the rocks near near
tracking foot but still being a bit of a
technician at the same time and that
that's intriguing he he his drawings
want to have the same angst as Pickler
but he's not from the Tarot and he is a
maker of bits and pieces and knows about
wise and so he's caught in a curious
slipstream
whereas rime and Abraham who is also was
was also Tyrolean could get closer and I
think again
Deanna talked about him this afternoon
so I don't to repeat what she said what
intrigues me about this which is my
favorite Avraham project doesn't matter
matter of fact because it was in a sense
usefully preposterous I'm fascinated by
projects which get to a point where you
have to think your way out of the almost
it's like tying somebody up in a paper
bag and then there he said could he'd
fight his way out of the paper bag
Pichler
sets up this extraordinary house which
it has mixed overtones part of it is in
the digging into the ground
Pickler tradition part of it is is is is
you know the Sinister going up into the
nowhere on the other hand the bubbles
drawn at that time could have only been
plastic at a notion of the plastic
bubble attached to this sort of creepy
Austrian cave-like thing is a wonder and
again it comes up in it as we saw this
afternoon in Pickler's nose object this
this sort of futurist object put into
the Austrian tradition of the sinister
Peter Wilson I think this is the most
mark it's not a very good slide but it's
a marvelous lost as far as we know lost
drawing part of that mysterious story of
whatever happened to the Metromedia
collection and it is the fountain house
Pete Wilson's very important infants in
the a in the 70s and 80s and this is
probably his most influential drawing
and and when one remembers the original
drawing it captured this almost
impossible to capture condition of steam
and water now that raises another issue
of I suppose under the heading of craft
but also the under the heading of trying
to touch the untouchable but that
sometimes in the drawing you're trying
to get to something which you know you
can never quite get but you must try and
if you're
beautiful technician such as Peter you
can get much closer on the other hand
there is the extraordinary attack of the
graphic of the graphic and the powerful
and almost bordering on the political by
which I don't mean politically in normal
sense but political in its in its
position in the trajectory of
architecture now one hears or one reads
or has been told that journey cough was
treated as a sort of just a graphic guy
by the by the real that the thevenin's
and and so on that he was not a bill he
was somebody did these marvelous perfect
but what I can report autobiographically
is that when I was a fifth year student
at the a iron three or four other people
heard about this book we heard about the
book of 101 fantasies and it was up in
the cupboard and the librarian would sit
behind you with the key watching that
you didn't lick the book I was told the
other day it's still up there Alvin
didn't have to sell it it's it still
lives and and it was the most
extraordinary thing I guess the term you
know it's full on it was pulling he's a
hundred and one things and they were
amazing and when years later I went to
Berlin and saw Ludwig layers own love
tank I knew it could be done journey
cough existed he exists in new laughs
tank but I digress not really because I
shall come back to churning up box when
I suppose was somebody that many of us
enjoyed to quote particularly destroying
and then and Ron and I were lucky enough
to meet him a couple of times and listen
to and watch him demonstrate his
universal joint and somehow this drawing
is an extension of that universality
what would Waxman have done with a good
computer my god you know in a sense he
anticipates a lot of the
parametric Petrus isms that that happen
now but he he or his assistant whoever
the hell it was had churning this thing
out and hoping that you didn't get the
line in the wrong place it remains so
that raises another issue is does it
have more power now because it was a
breakthrough
does it have power because some poor
bugger satin drew it hey where's
somebody now could go bang bang bang
bang don't go up the other end lovely
I'm not sure because we are too emotive
you remember Conrad batsman in his white
suit and his white ties and we remember
his kind of involvement you see there I
think my anecdote is talking about
something where the guy was involved in
an idea and if it had to be drawn it had
to be drawn if somebody had to mill the
steel to make the thing that had to be
milled and my god he nearly got some of
it built out in the desert that it never
quite happened um it was part of a
shared activity and to me the creative
moment if there was a moment the
creative condition existed between the
drawing and the thing turning and Connor
having this this preoccupation to me the
best drawings have always been knows
where the preoccupation dominated and
the craft came it was there and
someone's intrigued by known conditions
where a situation the sense is easier
I've always enjoyed Bernards clarity
another anecdote I remember was when REM
koolhaas came up to me in the a barn
said why didn't we win the competition
meaning this lovely net well I said
you're too clever by half because
Bernard is somehow able to hold quite
sophisticated ideas in the extremely
clear and simple way I've always felt
that about his work and here he was
Canyon ufff to not attempt to do a
complicated architecture
the figures in the sense you can say on
the right-hand side the the diagrams
that's what we might call them drawings
say virtually all there is to be sent at
the building we're about the building
when we look at the building on the left
just a little bit more yes yunda size is
darkened and really shiny but pretty
much the statement has been made by the
right hand sheet the left hand really is
the same thing that the blue sky behind
it now I'm exaggerating of course but I
think there are certain territories of
architecture where they are essentially
graphic at the architectural vocabulary
can be brought very very close to the
pre representation which also intrigues
me because now in my dotage on building
I realize that there are so many other
issues involved in most of the buildings
to make a simple looking building is
extremely difficult in many cases I'm an
admirer of Ito for many many reasons I
think he's been one of the most creative
architects of more or less my generation
anywhere and every five years he comes
up with something that was suddenly my
God has moved forward it's extraordinary
but what was interesting about these
three I think is the scribble which I
know was done after the event and a
typical a typical commercial Ito
building in Ginza and the way in which
this rather simple mannerism right can
be seen in the way that he organizes
other buildings that if you're on this
is just if you're onto a good mannerism
you can use it in plan section elevation
perhaps even three dimensionally but the
ITO is I think sufficiently self-assured
to be able to not glossing in a sense
the little diagram does say as much as
the other two drawings
but there are other kinds of mannerism
this interesting guy who was a student
at the bar that some years ago had been
before that an extremely ordinary bloke
he's a real sort of English ordinary
bloke ordinary bloke working an ordinary
bloke type offices and then suddenly
came and did this extraordinary thesis
project which now has been bought by the
museum on Martin you know and it was
also very strange because it showed a
creative cynicism which is not so
typical to the English in setting up
hypothetical three or four families of
Austrians I think in grants and their
lives and their words and their
disappointments and it was extremely it
was extremely sophisticated in its
narrative but also these drawings in
their self count almost a heraldic
quality well to me a very curious
intriguing take somewhere between
traditional English 19th century repro
heraldic but talking about the austrians
weird weird and then what's happened to
the guy he's back there his running
makes office in Hong Kong he's gone back
to being an ordinary guy ordinary bloke
architect wonderful I I mention this
because sometimes sometimes is it the
hot house of a certain kind of school is
it a retreat into drawing is it again
we're into psychiatrist couch territory
is this a certain way in which by almost
detaching himself from Austria being a
commentator upon Austria but actually
exposing a very rich and in inventive
psychology and mind but he uses the
stylization almost to hide behind one
wonders if in history there were there
were periods of drawing when it didn't
matter what you did as long as you hid
behind the manners
or the right kind of shirt drawing wires
you could hide your own personality into
it
I don't know I'm I've always been
fascinated by the John Patrick
phenomenon and I don't know the answer
but I mainly report you that phenomenon
it so this business of what you hired of
course is is that I I use this in I
haven't really looked at the book to do
this lecture I decided to to make the
lecture independent of the book but
there were one or two picks in there
that I couldn't resist this one in
particular because it's not an
architectural drawing it was commercial
drawing done in order to sell some kind
of show off period in design the Chicago
World's Fair and so to the taste of most
of us I suspect it's a pretty crappy
looking building it's a pretty bland
looking drawing it's a poster drawing
but it's it was selling what we would
have been believing in at the time so
it's it's presenting architecture not in
an architectural way but in a kind of
you know come to Blackpool kind of way
which is which is also curious hiding
hiding all the things that we've been
talking about today behind a kind of
bland populist condition all there is
craft as craft as craft I don't know
anything about Beresford pint except I
looked up the caption I guess he was a
good bloke and somewhat masturbatory in
his drawing technique I would say
thought a guy that says you know if
there's a patch of space here let's fill
it up you know there's another patch
that my god oh my god why not fill it up
you know keep it keep it always stuff
stuff stuff stuff stuff and stuff you
know everywhere there's stuff my god oh
oh
leave it alone but but it's fascinating
for that reason not even sure the
building could be on Harvard campus
sorry Yale campus wrong face there are
people who are immensely fascinated by
the issue of drawing this is by my
friend NAT chard who is at the moment as
marooned in the wastes of Manitoba but
should be rescued by a good faculty he
has just completed his PhD thesis which
includes 12 machines for the analysis of
drawing he's been teaching for 25 years
and all his students have made cameras
with strange things scratched into them
and all sorts of devices to do with the
analysis of drawings and his other
interest is in those in those set pieces
that you get in American museums with
foxes in the front but these these
machines are extraordinary because
they're concerned with the trajectory of
paint of the seizing of the moment at
which the surface is attacked and he
then makes them into an architecture
it's sort of asked about face in a way
or we have lebbeus now I think lebbeus
has been for many years fighting the
fact that he's such an extraordinary
technician his technique in drawing is
such that he makes the likely all the
unlikely look likely he can make
something that is almost preposterous
have patina and surface and structure
and he knows enough about building to
make it authentic and this was at the
time when his mother-in-law I think was
still living in in Ljubljana and the
stories are that labor is going in an
armored can't come out again I'm not
sure what it's holding a pencil at the
time or there is a question of people
who can really master technique and then
break out of it
see Jalen on the London scene is
probably the best architectural most
creative architectural drawer but at a
certain point received on the left his
his sort of standard-issue
production which may involve computing
yes and on the right at a certain point
about six years ago he broke out and
took the drawings and pull the drawings
off the paper so that they were were
they models not really because they were
still drawn they were created as drawing
but he broke through the boundary
between the flat drawing and the
three-dimensional object I fascinated my
notions of completeness can the drawing
complete I'm in in this piece of work
from their field of birds our fourth
year the fourth year project at the both
birds are so that you had to reconstruct
the Roman temple my suspicion is that
the Roman temple is reconstructed more
perfectly more amusingly more delicately
more lovingly than it ever probably ever
was when some guys in Rome just built
the bloody thing and I I think that
because that one could divert off onto
another subject which is the ways in
which the tradition of the occulta
bazaar has been useful to later
generations or not I provocatively wrote
in something in Paris not so long ago
that I thought the birds I hadn't been
quite such a bad thing because at least
it made people concentrate upon
organization which the French architects
are very bad at and I'm also fascinating
I haven't got an example here but just
in passing between the essential
difference between the birds are section
drawing and a modernist section drawing
because in the birds are section drawing
the theatre is important the surface is
important the section is just a white
patch that some guy who builds things
will come along and build but it is the
it is the facade the interior facade
actor that matters the modernist drawing
cost reverts reverses a whole thing it
is the profile
that is important the guts that is
important the rest doesn't matter mum
will return to that I think some of the
most marvelous architectural drawing of
course when done by a person as
brilliant as Enrique Reyes who's just
straight bog-standard positioning of
things and Reap was so inventive was so
extraordinary at rest
townhall extension was so inventive that
the positioning of all those parts and
the fact that one might be 43
centimeters in the other 42 centimeters
or whatever was what it was about it
didn't need special drawing because the
brain was was doing extraordinary
manipulation it raises the issue that if
of course the big sophistication or the
quality of the manipulation is enough do
we need a fancy drawing we just need a
drawing that gets the thing done and
perhaps I'm colored by my recent
experience of something coming around to
doing buildings and I have to admit that
I have I have more interest in this kind
of drawing as to what it it tells you
it's rather like score reading it can be
read almost like a score and you can
imagine the kind of architecture that
Morales may make in the vertical all on
that theme I come back to Mike Webb
because Mike Webb had this extraordinary
technique from about third year onwards
he could draw anything like a dream and
I think the the power of the furniture
manufacturers building was that it was
so precisely drawn it was so likely to
be real that what scared some people I
suspect was that you could build it it
wasn't a woolly drawing we always used
to get very irritated with our French
contemporaries because they always did
stuff that look like it would never hold
up never had any handrails and you
didn't know how it would be built we
guess the North Sea culture you know put
raincoat on hope hope it lasts and have
a good solid stick kind of psychology I
returned to my central point which is
identifying the creative moment and use
perhaps somebody wouldn't expect me to
use such as Eric Moss who talks like a
football manager but is in fact an
intellectual as you know and he
meandered around a project what is
intriguing between the first truck this
is him very sort of saying what he's
interested in somebody coming along and
then adding information onto rather Bob
standard production drawing and and the
question then and then somebody does
another drawing and you know it's lost
you know that somewhere somewhere
somewhere there was a point at which the
thing made its point and then in a sense
the later drawing there I say it is
gratuitous and ones when it attempts the
same thing with Christine's
shadow house and I was in watch her
doing it so the pencil drawing is not
full of indecision
it sets up a it sets up certain signals
the ink refined drawing clarifies what
she's trying to do and the colored
drawing is nice to have on the museum
war question where was the point at
which the project actually existed in
the sense went back to one's central
point where where is is is the moment or
all the part at which you start
salivating and when is it last though
the last one is more popular more
acceptable looks like something in a
recent project we did in our studio okay
they are computer drawings but the same
issue really is happening at one point a
certain manipulation of of the computer
model is dealing with tweaking and
compare
at another point it's dealing with
compiling some of the technical
categories at another point you're
manipulating somewhere somewhere there
are certain moments freeze
hey we're getting well I can say yes at
a certain moment yeah yeah you had the
same mental arm movement as if you had
the person yeah and then pressures of
life it's a pretty drawing the a no it
doesn't it does have a not completely
blue sky but the children are
suspiciously happy and the grass is
suspiciously well known and the concrete
work is suspiciously even but there is
of course this was a competition project
as you might gather and it is I sigh
caption it picture because I sort of
know that we've gone past it somewhere
but the picture is necessary but you
know that is lost in a sense
dare I says it's lost its lost that
meant it's gone into another world Oh
doesn't it look nice yes yes and the
guts of the of the issue of the design
issue are left behind I've been
fascinated by Ferris of course like many
and it's more New York than New York
really is and of course if you look at
the right fairy story as you can see
that it is a sort of process of of kind
of whittling down but then he stops for
me he stops at the irritating moment at
which he never really suggests what the
windows would do and I come from a
culture where the nicotine as' of the
window is the interesting part so that
this exercise stays detached maybe that
was very convenient for him maybe it
made him
usable by all and sundry maybe he didn't
know how to do Windows should I say that
Daniel was referred to earlier I have a
slightly different take and of course
there was Daniel of the of Cooper Union
of Haida importing to him his his
analysis
caboose a the caboose Ian parts at that
period when Daniel hadn't quite started
to explode things but my take on these
exploded drawings is that after I
remember of course that Daniel was a
classical accordionist it was a musician
and a good one and if you look at this
drawing and you work across it in one
dimension you can almond and you start
scoring it for sixteen staves of a large
Orchestra you start to see certain
compressions and contrivance system
diminuendo x' and counterpoints that
could very well be a musical score this
is my take on that that actually the
drawing is composed and has its
intensities misty intensities as would a
piece of of romantic scoring I I sort of
feel its hinder bit rather than
Stravinsky and so in a sense it's
refreshing to come back to Bernard who
can very succinctly perhaps to some of
you over simplistically make this
analysis between dynamic and structure
and yet even he is complicating the
issue I've had this slide for a very
long time and hadn't found a better one
so far but I admire the fact that a
ballet choreographer is dealing with
time and position and certain levels of
interpretation
is dealing with many dimensions and yet
we make these very complicated drawings
I think we should look more at
choreography drawings to make a more
dynamic architecture but that's not a
digression to me the drawing can say
what often we I mean II can't say
sometimes we did we dint say I think
that in the present architectural
climate many people are very afraid to
really say what is in their head they
say what they feel is an okay thing to
say and perhaps drawing is therefore not
an escape but an honesty even if you're
not very good at it
I suggest that just as a sort of a side
smirk went to Athens and made his own
take upon it it's not attempting to be a
rendition of the Acropolis it's all that
smirk needed to stimulate himself on the
subject perhaps or something ridiculous
like soccer this was old old favorite of
mine because it's silly I come from the
seaside you have to remember and if you
come from the seaside you understand
parasols and plants that are not the
right scale and doors in city places and
huts on sticks or maybe they're lollies
put lollipops that want to be hearts and
I think that that such such people are
immensely refreshing and the power of
the drawing is irresistible back to
Lemmy us because lebbeus uses all his
art he uses all his his considerable
knowledge of building and anger and
anguish and attack his his at times his
drawings have been very very worrisome
and then as he started to and as
everybody knows now he done
these amazing blogs as he started to
talk and write you realize it wasn't
just the technician wasn't just the
craft person it was actually a thinking
architect who happened to have this
ability as well there are people around
who who have a sort of very English
devil-may-care attitude will also though
he doesn't come from the seaside might
just as well he he makes his paintings
of objects that that hover near to being
the architectural piece and once you
know his work and the people who work
with him do you read the code and you
say oh yes yes what he's suggesting is a
building of you know 43 meters long and
28 meters wide and it will have four
Northlight trusses in it and it will use
his favorite kind of steel to properly
the upper gallery and and then it will
have an attack from holes or as Danny
was showing this afternoon rooms are
building with a sort of whirling
attacking it that is his spirit and I
know that from his way of working that
he he doesn't just do these pen he
doesn't sell the paintings he doesn't do
the prefect he does them and often just
then hides them but they are necessary
in order to get his creative juices
going now I can't paint as well as well
and many years ago I was trying to
summarize an attitude a kind of
atmosphere of something which I and I
wasn't on drugs so I had to draw it ice
I was intrigued by this notion of
floating and sailing as if you were on
some kind of cloud or surfboard or
something or something or something
because I was a graphic plotter
I borrowed stuff out of magazines and
drew between them and trying to get a
notion of off of a sublime state of some
sort much more recently and this is a
three year old drawing I've been
hovering around the idea of the question
whether a vegetated condition can have
ambiguous elements in it which are
tectonic
there are parts of the drawing that are
kind of rhetorically naughty
architecture so that there's this sort
of dunces caps or whatever they are in
the corner which are obviously created
objects and if you look at the drawing
you can find other places where there
are definitely pieces of organized
material metal probably glass probably
and but others were ones attempt to
summarize the drift of vegetation and
the drift of land at a point which does
virtually become organized as to say
there is no dividing line between the
natural and the vegetated and the man
contrived and how how near can we get
moments where there is no dividing line
between the one and the other so that
one uses and missus took a long time to
do its part of a large drink um use a
drawing like this in order to talk to
yourself about this ambiguous condition
or mark my friend Marcos Cruz who uses
draw a drawing to discuss another
uncomfortable and medias condition
between the idea of a skin a latex kind
of skin and the skin of a building and
the skin of a person and again a drawing
that moves in and out of that puzzlement
all there be us again who can drop New
York with a pen extraordinary wonderful
thing to do or mark West who spends most
of his time in Manitoba contriving very
strange pieces of concrete he's a
professor who with an institute that
that molds strange pieces of concrete
and name goes with as Mike Webb calls
him the king of graphite he got his a
former Hajduk student I explained and he
goes with his graphite and starts to
weave the sort of city that might be
made of that same concrete but for which
even the well-funded Institute can't
begin to provide and so it's
it's the day job becomes the night job
is it worthy the purse dust on the
drawing board is an extension of the
stuff hanging out in the laboratory in
sacks of concrete and stirrups and all
sorts of stuff fascinating or might web
who has his extraordinary ability to
pursue an idea and even a set of
drawings for 40 years his his obsession
with his home town of Henley Henley
where the Royal Mile is rode and his
obsession with the mathematics of seeing
and then in a recent lecture at the
Bartlett about three weeks ago he then
showed that he's done some new drawings
in the last half-year which this is not
one which overlay real positions of
objects on the drawing as a frozen
condition so that there is a battle so
to speak between the actual distance of
the mile and these relative positions on
the surface of the drawing which means
that one of them of course would be you
know hundred times bigger than the other
if it were then placed into I'm getting
tied up in knots here but but Mike would
would give a lecture about it whether
you'd know any more about it at the end
of it I'm not sure but he would give a
wonderful lecture and he's been
preoccupied with issues such as this
with issues of the world hidden behind
the object that the the obscured part of
the drawing becoming more important than
the bit that's overt and he returns this
is a this is a new drawing of his of his
other preoccupation of the vehicle that
inhabits the space that that you sit in
the vehicle and by turning the vehicle
you become part of this sort of egg like
house and there are I don't know 30 or
40 versions of this preoccupation and
this drawing and you notice rather like
the
Jimmy drawings in a certain way they are
actually quite simple drawings they're
actually very graphical but he hasn't
sold it yet now I know that Patrick is
talking tomorrow perhaps he will show
some of the work from their office I
being an old fart I suppose prefer the
work that they were doing at this period
I think it's much more interesting much
more original much more creative and I'm
glad to report that next to our site in
in Briona is of course our house
building which is bigger which is going
to be a stunner and looks much more like
this period of work though Patrick I'm
sure would deny it that intrigues me
well I think is is interesting in the
context of what I'm talking about
is is way back in the peak where the
drawing the painting of the peak makes
the city of Hong Kong anticipatory to
the peak it does a wonderful trick which
is by stylizing the city and emphasizing
certain diagonals and certain crevices
it suggests that the whole of Hong Kong
is up the peak building though in fact
you have to look hard to find the peak
building at the back there now I think
that is that can either be considered in
arrogance or brilliance turning your
building into the archetype of the city
that might be that is commenting on the
city that is but there is a degree of
concurrence to me as was talked about
this afternoon the issue of what has
happened to the plan and the section and
the elevation I cannot get out of my
head though I hear him lecture fairly
frequently on his newer work I cannot
get out of my head
Neil Denari is elevations I can't get
them out of my head they have such
power they have this power of hierarchy
I think you've been ordered that that
would have done him proud in their code
of bizarre of the 19th century meaning
that you can you can take a condition
and you can see the the relevance of the
part you can see the relative relevance
of the parts so clearly with immense
technique and of course Donora had as
has Pichler had in the smaller circle
Denari had an enormous influence upon
European architectural students during
the period approximately let's say 1985
to 2000 somewhere around that period
every second quart fairly I would would
look at from all over the place in
Europe would have denarii influence and
I don't even realize this but there is a
speaking as a North Sea person again
there is then the question of the gadget
you see I think that the gadget comes
close to the drawing sometimes this I
use this terrible word pernickety again
this sort of this business of tweaking
fiddle fiddle fiddle tweet no it's not
according it and then the specialness of
the drawing has and this has been
accused of many I think many people at
the Basset that there's been that sort
of tradition that intrigued with the
device was fashion it is very similar to
the obsessive drawing it's almost the
same thing except here it is a drawing
and again Gnaeus is when he wants to be
fantastic fascinating when you seeing it
see it come from another culture the
most interesting younger architects at
the moment around I think is his Aspen
Chan Chia who's a lady from Madrid
um who teaches both there and in London
and her take is also a strange piece of
mechanical machinery yet it could in no
way be in Glaser no way it could be
English but it suggests that there is
this subculture of the tweak of the
invent of the mad the mad inventor
condition and she is also a sufficiently
good drawer to find a obsessive way of
making it happen where somebody like
Stephen hull who is I think a marvelous
architect has a wonderful nonchalant
quite the opposite thing I deliberately
put this in at this moment to say it
isn't all fiddly really tweaking
tweaking tree sometimes it can just be
the light before you know well there's
been lot earlier this afternoon about
the quick burst sketch so move rather
quickly here because I'm in a sense
probably going to say similar things to
what was said earlier it is intriguing
to me that we can take and Niemeyer
sketch and if the culture is right for
it the building's pretty much like a
sketch it works in a culture where
obsessive detail is not on the agenda
it doesn't work in certain other
climates so therefore I'm digging around
Mendelson again the same as Donna I'm
rather amused by the slightly obscene
looking early versions of the tower I'm
intrigued by the rather boring versions
that it was you see what it suggests is
it it wasn't a quick flick of the wrist
he was there scratching away and
scratching away and doing more
scratching away and even the plan what
is intriguing about the plan is it sort
of Omri van the relative quality and
it's quite quite shocking in the sense
but there's a quick flick of the wrists
get just for those of you that say and
want to know that that you know
Mendelsohn did these quick sketches and
they're only so big and so forth
actually I wonder if it was a calm one
if he went home late at night and sat
there doing lots of them and then there
was the good one and it went there you
go I once another another terrible bit
of name-dropping anecdote but I once
went to have an interview with Oscar
nema and I got to the top and this lady
introduced me and he was standing at a a
sort of music stand with a charcoal just
doing his drawing okay Wein forward four
years my friend Peter prong from Oslo
said I saw Niemeyer recently said I went
up to the top of the flat and then he
was at the stand drawing with a charcoal
I said gotcha maybe that's what he does
you know they ring down they say we've
got some bloke from somewhere you know
coming up it's a whole [ __ ] get
something gets off his bay bed gets on
the old gets on the old now I'm being
cruel he's a hundred and nine or
whatever he's brilliant hope I make it
to that but um I'm intrigued by there is
also the the question of I'm being
somebody who has difficulty drawing I'm
not sure about the quick flick of the
wrist what intrigues me about this
building is of course in the sense it's
again it gets
near to that Cathedral of namaz it's
appears to be a simply detailed building
but hold it guys it pots done and it
rains and it has frost and what is
intriguing is it of course that there
were well and then the secondary thing
is you know if you're into if you're
into cutout windows the way the windows
are cut out is rather clever even if
it's all pumice stone and block work and
God knows what and chewing-gum behind it
- and then it's cemented over but
they're pretty good now weather weather
and I love to invent invent and
biographies I have not I'm not a good
historian it's time to invent it but you
can imagine life being what it is that
that Eric had you know Herbert or
whoever it was at his elbow and he said
Herbert sought the old windowsills out
and Herbert was a fanatic he would walk
away late at night making sure I think
that's another sort of drawing because
there is back to Neal there is the
obsession with the intention and the
kind of drawing that will actually get
it not the flick of the wrist but the
flick of the wrist in northern climates
maybe not in in Brazil in northern
climates needs another guy with a sort
of slower wrist or now of course with
the computer either been great with
Herbert had had a had you know my
crustacean
I'm intrigued by therefore on that basis
the fact that constant was booted out of
the Situationists Alka gram is always
being compared with the situation's
she'd straightness and I suspect that
most academics prefer the Situationists
because they were political made lots of
[ __ ] that they wrote and we wrote
different sort of [ __ ] we just drew
[ __ ] but what is interesting about
nits constant is that you can see from
these joints that he was actually
involved in the stuff he was working
away at him investigating drawing and
investing and probably got on up the
nose of the other guys who for whom then
they couldn't do that and they wanted to
be political all the time so they kicked
him out this is my take on the story but
I'm always intrigued I might web and I
went to hear him lecture and we were so
obsessed by the quality of his slides I
don't think we talked about anything
else for the next month don't think we
remembered any of the theory I I think
Sen who I taught together with for half
a year was the most extraordinary
product of what I could call the North
Sea culture here in this extra very
special location would be a cleft in the
rock and in the cliff you carefully
place a piece of building and look the
building is of the same basic ilk as
that sterling and gun drawing earlier on
there's some positioning things few
little deaf tweaks very simple drawing
but fan and I can almost still hear his
voice then we were at the end of the
world
and he makes the time but then the
intriguing thing is so he sort of
backtracking on this these very simple
postulates within that clip then what's
interesting about the drawing at the
bottom is it it's a positive negative
one it goes back to the simple
proposition of how you do it doesn't
tell you more than the drawing
previously it doesn't tell you less it's
just a slightly different way of doing
it do we confuse mannerism with the
creative act I have done a Mannerist
drawing it in fact sits in the archive
of the Royal Academy it is my diploma
work so to speak it's based upon my wife
city my wife comes from Tel Aviv I'm
fascinated by televisions the drawing in
a sense takes for me the most simple
easiest throw which is to do an
elevation drawing which summarizes a
series of ideas in a series of
personalities so each one we run each
piece of the kebab is in fact
representing a different entrepreneurial
type and then I place behind it a red
sky things can get bad in Tel Aviv but
the sky is never actually read but of
course the sky is not red and Cambridge
either and my teacher Peter Smithson yes
before me had done a red sky drawing and
it it stayed with me I recommend the red
sky if you want to make a simple
statement all the deadpan I think when
stones this drawing is like him for
those of you who know where's Jones yeah
that sort of rough don't don't mess with
me mana and here is a rough don't mess
with me piece of Usonian building made
of these rather boring panels and the
drawing says everything it's it's
in a way not a good drawing but it's a
great drawing because it puts its heart
in into the pieces many drawings that I
see now have a sort of strange over
consistency about them in a sense I was
praising this aha peak drawing because
it turned Hong Kong into her world but
here this assumed city standing outside
that window doesn't convince Andy and
and the rest looks like some kind of
endless wipeable plastic maybe it is I I
think I rather repeat what the Emerson
this afternoon which is that I don't
find the matter of of what is suggested
engaging I don't find it very agreeable
but maybe it's not trying to be whereas
this is of course trying to be extremely
agreeable this is a vacuum of who I
think is interesting sort of architect
artist staying very much within his own
culture not only accused of being a
paper architect but then doing a piece
of architecture on paper which is an
homage to his hero and then the paper is
a newspaper just so you got the point
we're in Russia guys and here it is and
it's red and it's in Russia dependence
chuckling and it's in Russia okay got it
right okay Yuri carry on um and I wonder
if I wonder if Piron AZ was a bit like
that have any suspicions
I wonder briefly go past grants only in
terms of couple of aspects of drawing it
or three aspect one the after the event
flick of the wrist sketch there was a
sketch one evening when we're done we'd
spent a month doing one version of the
competition and then said we're missing
it we're missing it we're missing it and
Connor and I just talked as we talked I
did this
thing which was the plan form that we
ended up with after the event I say ah
what's a building pinin skin then skin
done what do you do you go in bit of a
surprise done carry on then but really
one of the most interesting aspects of
the drawing of love love the project of
course is its its undulating pixelated
condition now the guys that put the
pixels in did these necessary working
drawings I suppose circuit drawings I
think could be anything clever guys but
the drawing has no but again circuiting
around trying to find the magic moment I
sat down and drew an elevation as I know
how I sat there with an ink pen drew it
put lots and lots and I can still
remember putting these dots in took
about a day I put lots of dots and said
that's what we're trying to get on the
surface we had a smart guy no works for
Gary one of our students and he he got
the old Photoshop and started to
manipulate yeah we sort of we're sort of
somehow coursing around it and then the
real you could never draw this
there is no drawing that would get it
and even when you take a still photo
because it's a still of something that
moves it doesn't get it and even you
don't get it because it depends on the
light quality the day time of day bla
bla bla bla bla so there's so many
layers but in the end you know that poor
old tradition of drawing it's never
gonna get near there but you've got to
draw around the idea in order to get the
conversation going
there was a reverse thing which was this
wonderful guy that sat in the corner the
whole time of the production of the
building doing these amazing logging
computer drawings that logged I think
there was 700 of them some horrendous
number that simply logged all the moves
being made
and progress of the building but the
other thing was that they were still
journey coffe sitting in the back of my
brain and the power of that journey
coffe drawing the notion of this
cantilevered thing that stuck out into
space but was sitting in my brain at
certain moments in in in in designing
the grants building I think that
intellectuals like the diagram because
it's sort of depersonalized 2d
architecture Eliza's you don't have to
have preference about window sills
mannerisms a few diagram at eyes enough
Leon's are interesting complicated guys
so he does interesting complicated
diagrams even Eric it's an interesting
complicated guy does less complicated
diagrams and in this particular project
where he were putting bandaging around
and that notion of an office block that
never quite happened until it becomes
stylized we know it's already lost it
somewhere and then makes an exhibit
which is really a three dimensional eyes
drawing which you know it's gone past
the moment at which it's interesting I
find figure ground diagrams tiresome
because then you tell you about one one
condition
I happen to know these buttons I know
what that diagram is saying it's much
beast pardon is much more interesting
that diagram yes there is the formal
street layout part and then there's the
hilly part with the with with the villas
on it but that's only just the beginning
of what it's really about yet color the
the finger ground diagram
dispassionately reduces it to that and
so I find these you know perhaps if you
have a certain if you if you assume that
all the architecture is of a moment and
you happen to know that architecture
very well it becomes like one of those
black-and-white maps of a town that
never really shows you whether a park is
even green I have that attitude to pick
the ground I think
it's been a tyrannical tiresome academic
way of looking at the presence of
objects and circumstances and I much
prefer Schwitters where every part has a
nuance and a history and a series of
possible interpretations but you can get
into those interpretations and he calls
this one complicated albeit that having
said that I admit to being fascinated
always by the Chancery competition
rascal and because it did a brilliant
thing in quoting a piece of pre-existent
Street and then turning that into an
architectural proposition he said then I
get irritated because yes there probably
are cue clues that it's a neoclassical
but with aspirin you can never be too
sure and one wants to know more about
the building even on that drawing so I
have a hate in brackets love-hate
relationship with the diagram and the
figure-ground and obviously so did so
did Raymond
so did Raymond Abraham he could he
couldn't make this Berlin proposition on
a figure ground he had to give it layers
of Thoroughly and angst and surface and
grasping you know I don't know when he
actually screwed the paper up but
whereas my friend Cedric was able to be
dispassionate and and and made made a
virtue of only just putting enough in
there this is one of his more
architectural I'm going to speed up now
cuz I know I'm running late I can see
your face and I mustn't go too fast
otherwise I'll spoil a show and I think
that his his his habit of having half
above the brandy reading nine newspapers
and making six phone calls before nine
o'clock in the morning was a useful one
in that enabled him to to quite honestly
present the strategy of a project in
whatever manners it needed to be
complementarily this is a form of of
diagram that goes it's it's too
sensitive just to be a diagram albeit
that when he did the occasional time and
he did a really formal drawing you can
look at it and you can see it as part of
an English tradition of people like John
Piper if one if one there's about that
kind of thing he could actually be quite
a discriminate he was actually a rather
good Drori
as interesting to me that chin chia has
many of the same approaches to Cedric
though done with a kind of Madrid Ian
interpretation you see drawings can
presume that all is not what it seems
this is a typical I don't know the guy
but a typical Bartlett project where if
we look at that house there are hidden
conditions there are very mechanical
conditions there are very elegant
conditions there are spooky conditions
and it is a computer produced drawing so
digitally produced drawing which has
carried on the same in a way almost the
same nuance as the tradition of Peter
Wilson and Peter and Abraham in its own
curious way and Chernykh off to could
hint and be explicit and be diagrammatic
all at the same time sometimes there are
drawers
that's intrigued you because you look at
it you say well that could only really
be on a drawing you know great nice
interests intriguing guy but but yeah
okay the existence of drawing that's
wonderful you know and I would get
irritated by people say that therefore
is is nothing to do with architecture he
said that he sometimes builds it gotcha
there are times haha there are times
when real there was a moment I think and
it still persists in certain parts of
Scandinavia where the tradition is to do
the drawing in such an ordinary way that
it doesn't in no way explains the
building I think Schneider sleeping was
one of the better guys around he did
that weird sort of strange like that but
he also did this bus garage if you look
at the bus couch probably better than
any of the bus garages you've got in
this town and yet the drawing makes it
look absurdly tiresomely boring so
they're far from the drawing taking the
architecture further it
so under sells it it's not true but
there is of course always this question
between reality and the invented
architecture after Gorman knew his
Corbusier who built his frida kahlo
house in a house for her big husband and
in in some time in some ways slightly
better than some of the court houses but
then went sort of crazier and crazier
and and and goes back into the into the
netherworld of Mexico and starts making
this architecture you can see from my
own drawing why I'm fascinated by this
kind of stuff all by my friend Marion
Coletti who using a computer can make a
vegetated world more wonderful than I
can ever use with paint and ink
nearly there Oh Hernan who I think is
one of the most evocative architects I
know I think I I'm a tremendous admirer
of his work and I think that he uses the
machine to be more seductive and curious
than many many drawers of the older so
we asked the question what where insulin
have done
with Maya let's say what would have done
is Rhino
I think and I say this again very aware
of where I'm speaking and there are many
words people in the architecture world
who need the story they need the symbols
they demand cultural references all the
time
whereas the drawing may actually be
about trying to find the sublime I held
back from using that dangerous word with
all its connotations but I think that
what I've been coursing around is an
instinct that some of us have well many
of us have as designers but there are
moments when you do sense the sublime
about some aspects of what you're
designing winners will never get built
on art and and I feel that the great
power of drawing is that it is part of
that search somewhere this is a project
where we won the competition but since
it's Sicily of course it never happens
and we're the pursuit of the project
lies somewhere between those two -
drawing somewhere between the know do
the hand movement the coaxing of the
thing using using digital processes and
then the interpretation of that coaxing
still also using digital processes and a
lot of drawing as well I end with a
picture of my friend Adolfo Natalie knee
another old European friend looking
pensive pensive with a pencil
what is he concerned about because his
made a drawing and he can only stand
back from it
how beautiful it would be if we could
all get up to the party and continue and
have a nice evening what a sinister fate
to be in this position and to be in this
position without even being an American
academic who could you know
authentically you know contradict when
Peter Cook says that academic stones
like craft
I'm not even austrian-hungarian only
Swiss and as a Swiss of course I find
Peter cook slightly crazy I mean I can't
help it
I always I always did and I continue you
know but then of course that's what I
like so anyway I shouldn't be longer
than than Peter in any case so I begin
with an observation then want to
formulate a nagging suspicion that
became more pressing as I was listening
to you this evening before finally
adding yet another small or not so small
example to the rather long of flood of
drawings we have been confronted with
today which I hope will bring us back to
some of the more general issues which
this conference wants to raise and I
apologize right away for the
archaeological or antiquarian character
of the four slides that I'm going to
show here is the observation not very
original because it has been made time
and again this afternoon architectural
drawing as we have seen this afternoon
evening is not just doing fine
it is thriving despite or maybe even
because of the mix of lamentations death
wishes
false alarms realistic assessments of
the dynamics of technology and
inconclusive mythopoetic ruminations
that have paved the ways of recent
architectural discourse and even of
today's conference and here is my
suspicion could it be that this thriving
success of drawings the surplus stock of
drawings on the marketplace of
architecture this undeniable condition
of overflow at least measured against
the number of architectural
representations handmade or not that are
required to get a project built has
ultimately less to do with building or
with architecture per se than with the
chemistry of visual culture at large in
which architecture is only one among
many partners and with the system's
boundless appetite for imagery that
surprises maybe shocks and in any case
entertains and with the extraordinary
capacity of a growing number of perhaps
otherwise jobless architects to feed
that very appetite the result being that
architectural drawing has steadily
emerged ever since the 1960s as an
autonomous pursuit not so much preceding
architecture but running parallel to it
emerging as it were as a third power
next to or between the traditional
protagonists art on the one hand and
architecture on the other after all many
of the drawings we've seen are now
stored in the museum if we want to
really see them we need to go to the
museum only if we do go to the museum we
can find out how infinitely more
beautiful and interesting they are than
they than we expected them to be on the
grounds of reproductions and on the
grounds of wonderful slideshows and here
of course I may be simply the victim of
a typical and definitely very
old-fashioned art historians prejudiced
in favor of the
original as opposed to the reproduction
my own epiphany with respect to certain
of those drawings such as for instance
this one and this is my only serious
critique with respect to the crazy Peter
Koch that he didn't show enough of his
own work as a matter of fact no very
serious my own epiphany with respect to
drawings like these took place in the
museum because only in the museum in my
particular case and that wasn't actually
this particular drawing but it was
drawings many drawings by Peter Cook in
my particular case it happens to be the
assaulter Pompidou it was in the centre
pompidou where I was initiated to the
incredible beauty of some of those
images because when I first came across
Peters work in magazines and then again
in magazines in 1960s and 1970s 1980s
all this appeared to me as rather
strange or to be honest rather
irrelevant as me I've been you know
mesmerised by this political [ __ ]
and you know that being sort of tried to
find intended to find interesting in the
1960s I found this rather irrelevant
because I couldn't help seeing much of
these things otherwise then as one to
one representations of things that are
thought to be as real while being just
too crazy in my eyes to be real
furthermore only the museum the
imaginary museum of art history allowed
me finally to understand these things as
being part of a discourse that really
does go much beyond London that goes
beyond the visual interests of the 1960s
helped me to understand for instance
that an axonometric like this one which
is actually a very straightforward
axonometry
that does indeed goes back to sterling
whom you Peter referred to in one of
your comments on the drawing but that it
also goes of course beyond sterling
at least to Duisburg and ultimately even
to schwa z he will probably agree that
at least Duisburg and his neoclassical
descendants of the wit Kovarian 1950s Oh
a certain depth to drawings like these
and of course I don't want to even
mention the slightly slightly well here
is something yeah I wanted to show the
in the plug-in City once again don't you
Maanshan I don't you want to mention
anything about a slightly Peron asian
opus reticule a tomb that seems to
envelope even to grow over in places the
high-tech machinery of this city
actually thank you Peter for having
shown there an easy although very very
briefly and use your talk but I think
it's perhaps more important then you may
have thought yourself now doubts as to
whether the traditional boundaries
between the shores of architecture
sculpture and painting or anything more
than an outmoded theoretical
construction artificially kept alive by
an equally outmoded yet highly
formalized system of education have been
around for quite a while here is Reena
Bonham 1956 in his review of the
notorious this is tomorrow show which he
measures up against the notion of the
synthesis of the major arts quote one of
the shining abstractions that gather
halo wise about the heads of its masters
adding that again Reena Bonham the most
used threshing-floor so far for the
synthesis has been cm and he continues
the idea of synthesis is something the
pioneers of the modern movement
inherited from the academies and passed
on to the Masters when the theme was
young it was simple painting was going
to lie down with sculpture and
architecture was going to lie down
smartly on top of them but in passing
from hand
and the theme has begun to split at the
seams some of the stuffing has come out
bats and bugs have got out have got in
and it is by no means certain as this is
tomorrow shows that architecture is
still top dog or that what sculpture and
painters produce is necessary is
necessarily painting or sculpture this
was nineteen hundred and fifty-six more
than half a century later one can't help
wondering that while artists and
architects and art critics continue to
follow widely separate curricula even at
a place like Yale that they actually do
and what they are interested in tends
more and more to turn around similar
issues and even to look the same this
situation I think has found in Peter
Cook both a prime symptom and as we have
now experienced an extremely eloquent
commentator thank god he spares us the
first truth truth encapsulated in
theoretical definitions instead he
invests a kind of curatorial curiosity
in the psychology of the act of drawing
and the drive behind it however despite
the truly cosmopolitan scope of your
wunderkammer perhaps it is your
Englishness that leads us to think that
your references to must be primarily
English while in fact they may be after
all more Slavic or austrian-hungarian as
you yourself now have confessed luckily
I am running out of time so you need so
you need not be afraid that I would
follow Nikolaus Pevsner in an attempt at
pushing you into the pigeon hole of the
Englishness of english art even though
at one point in your drawing book you
position yourself and you have done it
again in your talk as a late modernist
free former from the tradition of the
North Sea unquote which would allow for
the most adventurous critical shortcuts
from some of the work you like cope
himmelblau neighbors
when to Dominic even Zara did not to
mention Conrad bucksmom
to the extravagances of the English
perpendicular style in fact here we are
back with bucksmom what would Sir
Christopher you know would have done
with the computer
what would the late English
perpendicular gothics
would have done with the computer this
is my poor old you know laptop of two
years ago okay to conclude I think I'm
running on time
it is this drawing or these drawings
like this that a slightly been used
Heinrich lots must have had in mind when
he asked Louie calm in a conversation he
had arranged sometime between 1972 and
73 possibly here at Yale if he would if
calm would tear down Philadelphia if he
had a power to do it
Khan's answer was a decisive no quote no
because I wouldn't even know where to
begin the city itself becomes a part of
departure there is so much left in the
city which determines its path and
happenings so why then if he had no
intention whatsoever to tear down
Philadelphia did he imagined
Philadelphia as a sort of neo Roman
Fantasyland Klotz was not alone to be
irritated Edmund bacon the director of
Philadelphia's City Planning Commission
the 1956 TS considered these plans to be
quote just awful and I continued quoting
bacon Lou why did you conduct so brutal
an assault on the city you are reputed
to have loved why did you like the gods
of old wheel from the balls of
destruction on every nook and cranny of
downtown Philadelphia why did you buy
your ideas and proposals like the
bomber's of Iraq
try to obliterate every obstacle you
could find you realize that this is a
quote of 1991 and finally always bacon
the idea of making the parking of
automobiles the dominant symbolic
element of Philadelphia skyline is just
terrible why can't the conch League see
that this is so unquote
we know the story bacon the director of
the City Planning Commission dismissed
Khan's plans for the for he could not
read them otherwise than as a
representation of a project an image of
Philadelphia as Kahn wanted it to look
like that is an image of a real yet is
now on existing City evoked anticipated
by means of graphics and the same holds
true for clots with his similar
embarrassment he chose not to see the
drawing as what it obviously also is and
perhaps most of all both the result and
the means of a speculative exploration
of universals of urbanism such as
traffic the rights of the pedestrian
ecological the poisoning of inner cities
and the challenge of civic monumentality
or in a larger sense of the economy and
the poetry of private and public space
in a human habitat of today that calm
himself decisively saw it in that way is
illustrated by the fact that in the last
versions of the project he simply
replaced the Cee Lo's by a fray by a
freeway viaduct in fact he even was able
to understand Bacon's downright
rejection of his plans quote bacon is
interested in assembling good things and
putting them together
he said implying that if that is your
interest I mean to simply put things
together then there's no point of even
looking at my drawing and he continued
i'm premise minded interested in getting
to what is architecture what is music
and get in setting up forces to put
these things in motion on quote Edmund
bacon needed the telephone and a
typewriter to reject Kahn's project but
for the premise minded comm drawing
appears to have been indispensable for
setting up forces to put these things in
motion had he lived longer Khan would
have been surprised to see the success
story of premise mindedness in recent
decades thank you very much